you're good to go
an Indiana woman faces multiple charges
after a body camera video shows her
escaping from handcuffs and running off
from police says she was being detained
[Music]
on August 29th Evansville police
officers pulled over a truck for a
traffic stop officials say the woman in
the passenger seat 27 year old Malia
Smith had an affidavit out for her
arrest in a separate case that was drug
related video shows officers approach
the vehicle and asked Smith to get out
you ever find the insurance
um no I have to State Farm I think I
have an old car okay well he's gonna
he's gonna have you step out okay just
mind taking your seatbel offered I'm
happy step out as well
just face the door when you do you got
nothing I'm just gonna poke and probably
anything like that okay no weapons on
you I'm just gonna check and make sure
the responding officer can be seen
checking Smith for weapons before
walking her to the back side of the
truck
the bracelet fell off your pocket okay
all right just do me a favor come back
here all right
maybe step back here okay
step right here
okay all right is there anything in that
cars first is anything in that car yours
no okay next the officer places Smith in
handcuffs
[Music]
I will tell you in just a second
and you got nothing on you it's gonna
poke me stick me prop me anything like
that all right only thing I'll use a
brace on your phone yeah sure okay he
then explains there's an affidavit out
for her arrest was there an incident
that occurred a few days ago
I'm sorry is there an incident that
occurred a few days ago
um
and then I was great well was there
anything was there any I don't the only
reason I'm asking is you have a probable
cause to affidavit for your arrest out
right now okay I mean as of now I can't
see what it's I can't see here stay
right here I can't see necessarily what
it's for but I can only see that there
is one what does that mean it means that
you have a affidavit for your arrest I
mean you've committed a crime and
somebody
I've already confirmed with records okay
Smith speaking through slurred words
asks the officer to call a trooper he
then asks her to take a seat on the curb
excuse me
Trooper like it's my sister's so I do
not like I literally do not Cooper
um he's an officer okay because that
whole thing was completely messed up
here's the thing but can you please call
them are you are you are you on anything
right now no I'm just really upset right
now okay well thank you I will
your legs out go ahead and cross your
feet for me
can you cross your feet for me
there you go
the officer leaves Smith at the curb and
begins speaking with a truck's driver
that's when Smith slides out of the
cuffs and makes a break for it
it's ready back thank you sir so those
those items get them fixed all right
you're good to go
get on the ground
officers catch up with Smith after a
quick Chase and put the handcuffs on her
once again
oh my God
I'm cool
local TV stations report that after she
was taken into custody Smith complained
of pain stemming from drugs she had
swallowed before her arrest she was
taken to the hospital and later released
and booked into the Vanderburgh County
Jail Smith now faces multiple charges
including Escape resisting law
enforcement and possession of drugs or
paraphernalia the driver of the truck
was not taken into custody reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie